here's the thing the day after the
policy death threats started to roll in
and when I say death threats multiple
death threats I've I've been called
every name in the book but they messed
with the wrong Community our community
is strong um you know and they mess with
the wrong person to be honest with you
I'm a fighter by heart uh my mom called
me worse names like that then I was
little so when they do it it just rolls
off it's like okay come on bro find a
better word but you know and it's a
daily reminder of who we're fighting and
and who wants control of our kids
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the Chino Valley Unified School District
board president in Crazy California
Sonia Shaw Sonia welcome to the Reuben
report thanks for having me I appreciate
you guys so much
Sonia I did not know who the School
District board president was in Chino
Valley until a couple days ago believe
it or not when uh a video of you or at
least involving you went viral uh the I
want to get his name right even though
nobody should know his name your
California state superintendent Tony
Thurmond showed up to a school board
meeting you kicked him out can you give
us the backdrop on how this whole thing
played out or you know what let's throw
to the clip and then we'll let you
unpack it on the other side
you'll not bully us here in Chino please
see
no
one minute break chaos in Chino as the
state superintendent of Public
Instruction is escorted out of the
public meeting of the board of education
but what I saw here tonight was just
catering to a mob mentality that has
disregard for the safety of many of our
students who are vulnerable and at risk
yeah emotions explode as the state
superintendent ends his public comment
period bringing a heated exchange with
the school board president as a point of
order as the Border this is not your
meeting you may have a seat because if I
did that to you in Sacramento you would
not accept it please
all this as emotions run high with the
Chino Valley Unified School District set
to vote on a controversial proposal it
would require teachers and School staff
to notify parents if a child identifies
as transgender
what happened here this seems like a
whole bunch of controversy
you know Tony has a history with us here
in Chino first of all as a parent prior
to taking the seat my first board
meeting was this January we try to reach
out to Tony he had no desire to talk to
parents that didn't align with any of
his agendas or beliefs but he decided to
surprise us on that day and come to the
meeting but I found out through media
and they let us know he was coming he
ended up trying to do damage control and
and having a phone call with me which I
allowed
um you know I I called him back under
the direction of our superintendent and
his thing was it was like 10 minutes
before he knew we were in closed session
we come out I get on the phone I go out
to where all the crowd is and I said
what's up Tony you know exactly where
I'm at if you want to talk come talk to
me and he was like no no Mrs Shaw you
know he's started proceed we just we can
work together and let's just have you uh
reconsider the policy and I'm like Tony
I'm not playing your games I said not
not going to happen I said but look I'm
really glad that you want to work
together so how about this after the
meeting you have my personal cell now
it's on your phone let's reach out and
let's work on stuff for our kids and I
said but I have a meeting to run so I'll
see you in a few minutes and that was it
uh from that part
yeah so wait let's back up for a second
so for the people that are missing the
context of what led to this what was the
policy at the school and of course as
everyone can figure out this is related
to gender in the classroom and uh
teachers talking to kids and gendering
them differently and all of that stuff
what was the actual policy that you were
against that he and and seemingly the
entire apparatus of the State of
California is for yeah well you would
seem that that's what they say but I I
call them the political cartel is for
that but the parents aren't for that and
you know the policy was simple it should
have never reached Coast to Coast I'm
actually shocked it's in in this
position but look this but the policy
said something very simple it didn't
prohibit any lifestyle changes it didn't
prohibit or you know kind of break up
any you know the school district's
teacher
um and and child relationship what it
said was if a child wants to identify as
a different gender and be called that by
their peers and their t feature we're
going to notify the parents if the child
wants to go into the opposite gender's
restroom that they were born as then
we're going to notify the parents and
the same thing when it comes to If the
child wanted to play on the opposite
Sports gender that they were born as
we're going to notify the parents we
think here in Chino we see the confusion
and the perversion being pushed from our
department of Ed and our unions and you
know being a mother and just an advocate
for parents I said we're going to change
all this we're going to start putting
safeguards in place and when AB 1314
came out one of our assembly members
tried to propose a bill he said hey my
bill didn't go through the fair process
but I I'm telling you right now you can
develop a policy and I'm like policy is
our name that's what we do as school
board members so we had a coalition work
on a policy that was very mindful we
worked alongside amazing tourneys and
you know we dealt with the whole thing
on this is going to be illegal and I
kept pushing back with our
superintendent and I said show me the
law tell me the exact law because till
this day Bonte can't even tell us the
exact law we're breaking and the judge
even said it himself that the state is
trying to make him legislate law from
the bench that was his own words so I'm
like show me the law nobody could show
me the law and I said well it's time to
bring the policy forward I believe in
transparency brought it for her first
reading to allow people like Tony
Thurman and everybody to know we're
doing this and then four legs four weeks
later we brought it in for the vote and
that was the viral video that you um saw
um so yeah it's just to notify the
parents it had a couple other things on
there that you know as a parent advocate
and a parent we want to know and we know
that you know schools were keeping
secrets from I don't believe in keeping
secrets from a parent we're not the
parent and at now as a school board
member we definitely should not have
part into dividing the family unit and
and the policy wasn't very near and dear
to my heart it was three and a half
years of fighting our state
um it only made sense it was a common
sense policy
right so to be clear so you guys end up
voting four to one on a transparency
bill in some ways it's very similar to
what we've done here in Florida that
this is not about being bigoted or
anything else towards anybody it's just
letting the parents know what's actually
happening in the classroom then then
Tony shows up and he basically called
you guys a bunch of right wing Mega
extremist uh I don't know a ton about
Chino but I know a bit about Cali I'm
I'm guessing you guys aren't hardcore
extremists are you no we're parents we
just want to be involved and the name
calling has gotten out of control but we
are literally showing our kids even
though you're bullied in your name
calling you don't respond that way you
respond and stand strong and you know
nobody saw behind the scenes Tony
Thurman throughout the meeting before
you know I had my words with him he was
calling point of order during the middle
of the meeting he was yelling out and
I'm like I gave him the eyeball like I'm
a very for fair board president because
I know people are passionate when it
comes to these things and I allow you
know some but I don't allow craziness in
the boardroom my job is to keep it going
and do the board business he was
interrupting multiple times I gave him
uh you know very much amount of a Grace
because of who he is and I was trying to
allot him his his time and then when he
got up to speak I I had enough I'm like
you know what I'm the parents voice I'm
gonna tell you exactly how we feel and
it was clear that the other parents at
least in the meeting
certainly agreed with you do you have
parents on the other side that disagreed
to parents show up and say no we should
not know what's going on in the in the
classroom or is it all just kind of
state funded people that show up that
have no skin in the game because their
kids aren't at these schools you know
what's really funny is here's the thing
we have activists um here that obviously
are against us we unseated somebody that
was really deeply involved in this whole
agenda they're mad they she developed a
group and they have their people coming
after us but my question always to them
is yeah you don't like me you don't like
what I'm about you want to call me all
these names but do you want us as a
school district to hide the secrets and
I've never gotten the answer yes I'm
cool with that so my point is why are
you fighting us on this it's common
sense right
um but you know people are going to be
people and they're going to allow the
division and I think it's sad but I will
tell you this the majority why want us
to stand strong in this and not allow
the secrets and continue to put policies
in place to fight back on you know our
dictators here up in California
can you talk about a little bit about
what it's been like for you personally
dealing with this I know you're getting
a lot of threats and all that sort of
stuff and you know I've over the years
of doing this show I've interviewed a
lot of people like you who were not
public people who were just trying to do
the right thing either related to their
kids or their company or whatever it
might be and then just get thrown into
the fire I I kind of sense you're you're
into the fire
yeah well you're in it whether you like
it or not but I kind of sense you're
into it hey I'm not going anywhere you
know here's the thing the day after the
policy death threats started to roll in
and when I say death threats multiple
death threats I've I've been called
every name in the book but they messed
with the wrong Community our community
is strong um you know and they mess with
the wrong person to be honest with you
I'm a fighter by heart uh my mom called
me worse names like that then I was
little so when they do it it just rolls
off it's like okay come on bro find a
better word but you know and it's a
daily reminder of who we're fighting and
and who wants control of our kids right
so when that stuff started to happen I'm
not gonna lie the very first day I
freaked out
um but you know it's no secret I'm a
Believer I dropped on my knees to God
and asked him okay are we gonna be okay
like this is a little wild and I had as
much um you know yes yes yes you are and
I was like let's go let's fight you know
because we're in in it for the good
fight we're in it for the right reasons
and you know Dave they try to divide us
they try to make this Maga red red
versus blue Christian versus
non-Christian gay versus non-gay I mean
they try but when it comes to our kids
we can fight this together and I think
that's the most beautiful thing to show
our kids is despite them trying to
divide us and keep us on on two
different sides or three different or
four different how who even knows what
they're doing right now they're so
embarrassing
um you know we're showing our kids no
you're worth the fight we're gonna do
this and and you know people have come
to our families um safety I mean our
Chino Police Department is amazing
um we have extra Patrol we have people
wanting to stand guard in front of my
house
um you know so
it's been wild but I I'm appreciative
that I was given this opportunity to
fight for our kids I never regret saying
yes three and a half years ago when I
joined this fight and I don't regret
today and I don't regret all the
craziness with it I actually
um am grateful I'm grateful because I
see communities coming together and
that's beautiful
so even though you guys kind of got the
temporary win here and that the board
voted the way you wanted so transparency
at school now you've got the
superintendent uh the Cali State
superintendent basically going against
youth this Tony Thurman guy uh you
probably know how Gavin Newsom feels on
this thing and now you see other bills
going through the state like if you
don't affirm your child's gender or what
gender they perceive they are they could
potentially take your kid away I mean do
you see this as just the first fight of
many that you're gonna have to that all
of you guys are gonna have to go through
you know
and breaking the family
you enable but I will say this Dave
people like me three and a half years
ago never even watched a bill we didn't
even know what hit us and then finally
when it came into our home you have all
these people all over California uniting
you have moms and dads in Sacramento
fighting the fight over there you have
us over here locally in each of our
communities
um
it's it's a sad situation but I think
what it's doing is it's bringing
awareness it's bringing people together
957 is horrific all these things that
they're pushing through our educational
system is horrific they're trying to
make Community uh schools you know and I
see that as a gateway to take control of
our children they're trying to package
it as whole child and it's like excuse
me I don't want you to take care of my
whole child that's my job as a parent I
think it's very weird but you know
people are starting to come to the fight
so I think their time is almost up and
you could see them panicking they're
panicking because they're passing
Reckless bills their mouths are Reckless
so normal day-to-day people just trying
to provide for their family are saying
Sonia did he just say that on TV and I'm
like yes he did thank you that was
another gift because you just brought
another parent to this fight right yeah
so how old are your two children
children
um I have a just 14 year old she's a
freshman and I have a junior who's going
to be 16 in like two weeks so as you may
know I have two boys who are about one
right now and so obviously we're not
into this fight yet and I also live in
Florida where things are are very
different by Design but can you talk a
little bit about how this is like for
your for your kids and and their friends
just that the atmosphere around all of
this lunacy absolutely so my kids get is
that your mom on the school board is
that your mom on the TV and now they
just know and you know what's really
cute is they send messages
um to my kids from the parents like the
parents will say hey tell Sonya's
um you know daughter that we said we got
her back or whatever even teachers I
love it because we have they try to pin
unions uh against the parents and they
drag the teachers in it but we have many
amazing teachers actually fighting with
us right and doing the right thing
um so you have teachers reaching out my
kids my kids are rock stars I I am very
grateful I have two amazing strong
daughters who I don't I don't even know
sometimes I'm like where did that come
from you know
um I would probably think one of my
daughters is a Maga she has a big old
Trump sign and that was all by her and
her room
um I don't know I and you know
I'm grateful for two amazing kids it has
been adjustment because I am a Hands-On
in the classroom mom always there
um and they've had to adjust they but I
think it's good too because you know
growing up out without involved parents
I was probably overly involved and now
it's allowing them to really just be who
they are and I see them just you know
they have a great Foundation thank God
and my kids it's crazy they're not even
afraid I mean sometimes I'm like okay
guys we got to take these precautions
this is real you know someone wants to
cut off our limbs we gotta do this and
that and look over our shoulders
sometimes but they're they're good
um I have they have an amazing counselor
too who has helped them every step of
the way and she's you know made sure
their classes are unchecked and as long
as my kids are taken care of hey you
know I could do I could do this fight
and luckily everything's in line but I
have good I have great kids what do you
make of the broader fight happening in
Cali right now because you know every
day when I do my show we could just do a
hour of insanity about California every
single day and you know sometimes we do
and then sometimes I'm just like all
right if that's what the people at Cali
want let them have it I mean do you
think California can be turned around
it's become a one-party State obviously
uh Newsome seems to have his eye on a
bigger prize it seems like the machine
there is just very calcified against
parents even if you can get little wins
like this yeah but you know what look at
what these little wins did Dave it
brought people awareness this so I think
we're just in the beginning right but I
see people coming to the fight ready to
just give their all I don't think that
we're going to win this overnight I
think this is going to be a long
Marathon battle but I see a lot of
commitment I see continuous incoming
commitment I see teams being brought
together
um I mean you saw too we just recently
um you know put on a liberty Justice
Center we have people uniting all over
the United States to help us and I think
they know if we don't fix this in
California you're gonna have to fight it
in your state eventually you know
everything trickles down so I I think
that's the good thing is we're all
starting to come together I never
imagined this I never imagined flying
across you know the coast or the nation
uh to go talk to other people about this
this is wild but it's also encouraging
because I know in my heart if we all
just stick together and we don't let
them label us and divide us I think we
have a chance and and imagine California
showing the nation you got this I mean
we were discredited a long time ago and
us as parents are like hold on wait a
second we're here what could we do how
can we fight
Dave I could tell you stories about the
things that we've done and held our you
know local elective officials
accountable and I see that starting to
happen all over California so I say
their time is limited it's almost up
it's a matter before we have people who
actually love their communities in those
seats listening to their communities and
working alongside them but it's going to
take some work and I am absolutely
hopeful that we're going to get those
Warriors in in this battle
wow well
you also became a professional in being
interviewed because that's how you end
an interview oh my gosh
I don't know that I can add anything
else to that unless there's anything
else you want to add because I think
that that sort of Hope is is always what
people need even when a guy like me has
fled a place like Cali no and see you
fled but you're still part of the battle
Dave you're still with us come on
shoulders
We we played that video uh on my show a
couple days ago and I immediately I
think I said it on air we gotta find her
and get her on the show and we we got
you within an hour because because
people like you are the ones that are
going to turn this around it's not just
all the Talking Heads yeah and we need
to encourage people if a soccer mom
without going to college could do this
guys you could do this too I promise you
just have to give your yes and we're
good we're in this I mean we're all
linked arms I see it all over I'm
hopeful Dave we appreciate you and all
that you do do not uh ever give in to
the big old bullies
um the political cartel is done they're
they're being dismantled they're
embarrassing
um I I we got this don't even worry
about it there's a little inspiration
for you if people want to help out where
where can we point them okay so a couple
things you can go to Liberty Justice
Center
um I put a link on my social media my
social media is we'll link to it down
below as well
um Sonia Shaw s-o-n-j-a and then Shaw
2026 I had to open up my 2026 account
because the CTA is after Sonia Shah and
you and you know we got to make sure
that people like me stay in the fight
but um Liberty Justice Center is an
amazing thing
um I I would say start with those two
places we love the support we love the
encouragement Dave I want to say one
thing I have a stack this big of
postcards and cards handwritten cards
that's despite all the emails that
people are sending all across even the
world now I get people Another You Know
Places other countries saying we love
you guys don't give up and I'm like oh
my gosh this is wild but yeah we
appreciate the support and love and
encouragement
Sonia I wish you the best of luck in
Crazy Cali thank you so much
it's about politics instead of non-stop
screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell